[Music]
thank you thank you so I've been
thinking about things that I'm happy
about and what I'm most happy about so
far is that I haven't spilled my my
bubbly water into my computer so far
while I've been doing these lectures
that's always I'll probably do it
tonight now that I'm bragging about
having avoided it so thank you all for
coming this is the last lecture in this
12 part series I did mention that I have
made arrangements with the theatre at
least to do this once a month for the
next four months and we'll see we'll
play it by ear past end I want to
continue and I'll find another venue and
perhaps to do it every two weeks but
certainly once a month and maybe I can
even get deeper into the material if
it's only once a month so that would be
then and then we'll really slow down to
a snail's crawl yeah so this is a tough
one tonight you know it's something a
story that everyone with any sense
should approach with a substantial
degree of trepidation I've been working
on my book this week on Chapter 7 which
is called do what is meaningful not
what's expedient and it's really it's
been a very difficult chapter because
I'm coming to I'm trying to to extend my
understanding of sacrifice which is of
course what we're going to talk about
tonight in great detail and and I've
been wrestling with exactly how to do
that and I'm going to read you some of
that I think today don't generally read
when I do my lectures but this is so
complicated that I'm not confident of my
ability to just spin it off you know
sort of what would you call it
spontaneously that's the word and so and
it'll also give me a chance to test out
whether what I've written which I've
been struggling with has the kind of
poetic flow that I'd like to have if
you're writing it's really good to read
things aloud you know because you can
tell if you've got the rhythmic cadence
right then so so anyways thank you all
for coming many of you have I believe
attended all 12 lectures and that's
really remarkable it's amazing that you
know this place has been full every
single lecture it's completely
unbelievable that would be the case and
you know about more than two million
views of this is being watched more than
two million views it's not 2 million
people because it would be the same
people I would suspect many times but
that's also crazy but it's a crazy world
and it seems to keep me getting crazier
so hopefully this is some addition to
stabilizing it and making it slightly
more sane that's the hope anyways so
we've got a couple of stories to deal
with tonight complex complex stories not
really easy to comprehend in any sense
of the in sense of the word I mean with
the story of Isaac God calls on his his
chosen individual Abraham the person
who's made this contract with to
sacrifice his son and it's how in the
world are you supposed to make sensible
any sort of sensible sense out of that
it's exactly that sort of story that
makes modern people who are convinced
that the faster we put the biblical
stories behind us the better it's it's
grist for their mill you know because it
seems like such a incomprehensible and
even barbaric act on the part of God and
so you know I hesitate to even approach
it because well because there's so many
ways that the an interpretation of that
sort can go wrong but we'll see how it
goes and so let's walk through it and
see what happens so we start with the
story of Sarah and Isaac and the Lord
visited Sarah as he had said you
remember when Abraham was in the midst
of his appropriate sacrificial routines
which we've characterized as his return
to the contract he made with the idea of
the good the contract with God he was
informed by God that he would get what
he most wanted which was an error and it
despite his advanced old age and of
course Sarah was very skeptical about
that as she had every reason to be but
this story opens with with the
fulfillment of God's promise to Abraham
and the Lord visited Sarah as he had
said and the Lord did unto Sarah as he
had spoken for Sarah conceived and bore
Abraham a son in his old age at the set
time of which God had spoken to him and
Abraham called the name of his son that
was born unto Him whom Sarah bear to him
Isaac and Abraham circumcised his son
Isaac being eight days old as God
commanded him had commanded him
and Abraham was a hundred years old when
his son Isaac was born unto him and
Sarah said goth had made God had God
have made me to laugh so that all that
here will laugh with me and she said who
would have said unto Abraham that Sarah
should have given children suck for I've
borne him a son in his old age and the
child grew and was weaned and Abraham
made a great feast the same day that
Isaac was weaned I suppose one of the
one of the purposes let's say perhaps
the literary purposes of this story is
to exaggerate for dramatic purposes the
importance of a child you know when
people are young and I think this is
particularly true in the modern world
they seem to often regard the
possibility of having a child as an
impediment to their lifestyle you know
and of course in some ways I suppose
that's true although you have to have
quite a lifestyle before a child
actually constitutes an impediment
because having a child in your life is
actually something that's remarkable
almost beyond belief you know you can
have a relationship with a child that is
better than any relationship you've ever
had with anyone in your life if you're
careful and if you're fortunate
fortunate being fortunate helps you know
I've seen many people delay having
children and for understandable reasons
it's no simple decision to have a child
and of course now we can make the
decision to have a child which of course
people couldn't in in past ages really
but sometimes you see people delay and
they delay too long and then they don't
get to have a child and then they're
desperate and you know they spend a
decade doing fertility treatments or
that sort of thing and immersing
themselves in one disappointment after
another and it's just at that point you
see exactly how catastrophic it is it
can be how catastrophic it can be for
people not to have one of the not to be
able to undergo one of the great
adventures of life let's say and one of
the things this story does by by
delaying the arrival of Isaac and
delaying the arrival of Isaac
continually is to exaggerate the the
important significance of the child
because it is
until you're deprived of something it's
truly not until you're deprived of
something that you have any sense of
what its value is and Isaac was waiting
or Abraham was waiting a very long time
a hundred years a very long time
and the same with Sarah and so they're
unbelievably excited and of course this
also heightens the drama that's inherent
in the entire sacrificial story because
it's not only that eventually that
Abraham is called upon to sacrifice
Isaac which would be bad enough under
any other any circumstances whatsoever
self-evidently but the fact that he's
been waiting a century for the arrival
of this child desperately and made all
the proper sacrifices and lived in the
appropriate manner to allow this to
occur dramatically heightens the
literary tension now you remember Hagar
this is the next part of the story Hagar
was is was Sarah's handmaid and when
Sarah was unable to bear abraham a child
she sent him Hagar and Hagar immediately
got pregnant and and gave birth to
Ishmael and the story picks up from that
point here and if this is quite
interesting I mentioned the other week
when I was talking to you guys a couple
of weeks in a row just how interesting
it has been to scour the internet for
the for the paintings that are
associated with these stories there's
just a there's an amazing wealth of
great paintings that illustrate every
single bit of the of every single
biblical story and it's it's it's a it's
really been enlightening to me to find
out just exactly how poorly educated I
am you know like I I'm a what would you
say I'm I'm a great admirer of artistic
talent and of artistic endeavor but
there's so much I don't know about the
history of art that it's just absolutely
beyond belief and to see this treasure
trove of images that I really had no
idea that existed of course they're
spread all over the world and it's only
been in recent years that you could have
access to them and in this way just it's
just it's a it's a it's a constant
revelation of the depth to which these
stories have absolutely permeated our
culture and the loss that it would be
if we didn't know them properly and and
take them with a degree of seriousness
that they deserve so anyways this is one
of those great images and Sarah saw the
son of Hagar the Egyptian which she had
born unto Abraham mocking wherefore she
said unto Abraham cast out this
bondwoman and her son for the son of
this bondwoman shall not be heir with my
son even with Isaac and the thing was
very Grievous in Abraham's sight because
of his son was being quite a bit of
tension between Abraham or between Sarah
and Hagar as you could imagine there
might be why wouldn't there be I mean
first of all Hagar had the first child
and and that elevated her status and she
was Sarah's made handmaiden so that's
obviously going to be quite awkward and
then she she lorded it over Sarah
because of the fact that she got
pregnant so easily and now we see this
situation where Ishmael is doing the
same thing with regards to Isaac and
that causes a substantial amount of
trouble the family is a familial
division occurring here God said unto
Abraham let it not be Grievous in thy
sight because of the lad and because of
the bondwoman in all that Sarah hath
said unto thee hearken unto her voice
for in Isaac shall thy seed be called
and but also of the son of the bondwoman
will I make a nation because he is thy
seed that's so that's it that's an
interesting outcome to you know we we
pointed out before we discussed before
the fact that because Abraham has made
has lived his life properly and has kept
the contract with God there's every
evidence in the story that no matter
what the vicissitudes of Abraham's life
you know how the Great Serpent that he
sits on in some sense weaves back and
forth there's always the promise that
things will work out positively and you
know you could read that as naive
optimism but I think it has a lot more
to do with the actual power of keeping
the contractual agreement because I
really do believe and I've spent a
tremendous amount of time thinking about
this over the last couple of weeks in
addition to the decades before that is
that it and all that's happened since
I've been doing these biblical lectures
is that my conviction in this is being
strengthened which is quite interesting
is that
if you if you do what it is that you're
called upon to do which is to lift your
eyes up above the mundane daily selfish
impulsive issues that might be set you
an attempt to enter into a contractual
relationship with that which you might
hold in the highest regard whatever that
might be to aim high and to and to and
to make that important above all else in
your life that that fortifies you
against the vicissitudes of existence
like nothing else can and I truly
believe that that's the most practical
advice that you can possibly that you
could possibly receive you know I
received I was answering questions last
night I did this Q&A which I do about
once a month for for the people who are
supporting me on patreon which I also
release on YouTube and somebody asked
you know they were struggling with their
religious faith and they asked what they
could do about that and I'd also been
thinking about the the difference
between Nietzsche and Dostoevsky which
I'll discuss in a minute and I was
trying to answer this question with
regards to religious faith because this
person was shaky in his faith in life
let's say which is a better way of
thinking about it and and it seems to me
that the way that you fortify your faith
in being and in life and your own
existence isn't to try to convince
yourself of the existence of a
transcendent power that you could
believe in the same way that you believe
in a set of empirical fact I don't I
don't think that's the right approach I
think it's a weak approach actually I
don't think that the cognitive
technology that I don't think that's the
right cognitive technology for that set
of problems you know that's more
technology that you'd use if you're
trying to solve a scientific problem
it's more like it's more something that
needs to be embedded in action rather
than in stainable belief and the way
that you fortify your faith in life is
to assume the best something like that
and then to act courageously in
relationship to that and and that's
that's tantamount to expressing your
faith in the highest possible good it's
tantamount to expressing your faith in
God and it's not a matter of stating
well I believe in the existence of a
transcendent deity because in some sense
who care
who cares what you believe I mean you
might and all that but but that's not
the issue it's not the issue the issue
it seems to me is how you act and I was
thinking about this intensely when I was
thinking about Nietzsche and Dostoyevsky
because of course you know that
Nietzsche was the philosopher who
announced the death of God right and who
was a great great critic of Christianity
at vicious critic of institutional
Christianity in the best sense you know
and he announced the death of God and he
said that we'd never find enough water
to wash away the blood it wasn't a
triumphant proclamation even though it's
often read that way and don't choose
conclusion from that from the death of
God the fact that our ethical systems
were going to collapse when the
foundation was pulled out from
underneath them he believed that human
beings would have to find their own
values to create their own values and
there's a problem with that because it
doesn't seem that this is something Carl
Jung was very thorough in investigating
it doesn't really look like people are
capable of creating their own values
because you're not really capable of
molding yourself just any old way you
want to be like you have a nature that
you have to contend with and so it isn't
a matter of creating our own values
because we don't have that capacity it
might be a matter of rediscovering those
values which is what human was
attempting to do now and and and so I
think Nietzsche was actually profoundly
wrong in that in that recommendation I
think he was psychologically wrong now
you know Dostoevsky wrote in many ways
in parallel to Nietzsche was a great
influence on Nietzsche their lives
parallel each other to a degree that's
somewhat miraculous in some sense it's
it's quite uncanny Dorothea Eskie was
obviously a literary figure whereas
nature was a philosopher a literary
philosopher but still a philosopher and
Dostoyevsky wrestled with exactly the
same problems that that Nietzsche
wrestled with and but he did it in a
different way he didn't literary matter
and he has this great book and The
Brothers Karamazov and in that book
there's a hero of the book is really a
lyosha who's a monastic novitiate a very
good guy kind of not an intellect not an
intellect but a person of great
character you know and but he has a
brother Ivan who's his older brother
who's a great intellect and and a very
handsome so
a brave man and like Dostoyevsky's
villains Ivan isn't exactly a villain
but that's close enough
Ivan our Dostoevsky makes his villains
extraordinarily powerful so if dusty
esti is trying to work out an argument
he he closed the argument in the in the
flesh of one of his characters and if
it's an argument he doesn't agree with
and he makes that character as strong as
he possibly can as strong and as
attractive and intelligent as he
possibly can and then he lets him just
have at her and so Ivan is constantly
attacking Elly OSHA and from every
direction trying to knock him off his
perch of faith let's say and and elosha
Alyosha can't address a single one of
Ivan's criticisms and and he doesn't
have the intellect for it and and and
Ivan has a devastating intellect it's
devastating to him himself as well what
happens in the brothers karamazov
essentially is that Alyosha continues to
act out his commitment to the good let's
say and in that manner he's triumphant
it doesn't matter that he loses the
arguments because the arguments aren't
exactly the point the arguments in some
sense are a side issue because the issue
is and this is the existential issue the
issue is not what you believe as if it's
a set of facts but how you conduct
yourself in the world and so Dostoyevsky
he grasped that and it's one of the
things that makes him such a amazing
amazing literary figure an amazing
genius because he was smart enough to to
formulate the arguments in a manner that
no one else really could with the
possible exception of Nietzsche and
that's quite an exception and yet he
could still using his dramatic
embodiment he could still lay out
solutions to the problems that he was
describing that are extremely compelling
and both crime and punishment which is
an amazing thrilling engrossing book and
The Brothers Karamazov all of dusty-ass
Keys great books really circulate around
around those profound moral issues and
so I've learned a tremendous amount from
reading him so and God said unto Abraham
let it not be Grievous in thy sight
because of the lad and because of thy
bondwoman and all that Sarah hath said
unto thee hearken unto her voice for in
Isaac for in Isaiah Excel shall thy seed
be called and also of the son of the
bondwoman will I make a nation because
it
as I seed alright so I commented that
Abraham is being blessed in multiple
directions even when things are going
wrong and this is pretty bad because his
family in some sense is breaking up the
there's this emphasis in the text that
because he's kept this contractual
relationship with God that that he's in
an arc we could say at that we could put
it that way and that the that he'll
he'll triumph through the vicissitudes
of life which is the best you can hope
for and it's quite interesting again one
of the things that's so powerful about
the Abrahamic stories is that it's not
like Abraham even though he's chosen by
God it's not like he has an easy time of
it he has a rough life I mean it's a
successful life and all that but it's
not it's not it's not it's not without
its troubles that's for sure it's got
every sort of trouble you could possibly
imagine pretty much and and that's one
of the things that makes the story so
realistic as far as I'm concerned and
Abraham rose up early in the morning and
took bread and a bottle of water and
gave it unto Hagar putting it on her
shoulder and the child and sent her away
and she departed and wandered in the
wilderness of Beersheba I found the
funny I guess this had more of an
emotional impact on me this week than it
might have because my daughter just had
a baby a week ago and so I've been
thinking about this sort of thing know
was so happy that that's happened and I
was trying to put myself and uh what
would you say the conceptual space of
the people about who these stories or
people who these stories are about and
trying to you know notice that the
catastrophe that this sort of breakup
would actually constitute and you know
and the visual images really helped with
that because they're they're so
carefully crafted and and they hid the
story from so many different directions
that you know they add that an
additional layer of ocean meaning to it
which I found very very significant and
the water was spent in the bottle and
she cast the child under one of the
shrubs and she sent to wander in the
desert you know so it's not just that
she has to leave
Abraham's household it's that where she
goes is not really amenable to life and
so it's it's an extraordinarily dramatic
and terrible tale and she went and sat
her down over against him a good way off
as
were a bow shot for she said let me not
see the death of the child and she sat
over against him and lift up her voice
and wept and God heard the voice of the
loud and the angel of God called to
Hagar out of heaven and said unto her
what aileth thee Hagar fear not for God
have heard the voice of the lad where he
is rise lift up the loud and hold him in
9 hand for I will make him a great
nation and God opened her eyes and she
saw a well of water and she went and
filled the bog with water and gave the
lad drink and God was with the lad and
he grew and dwelt in the wilderness and
became an archer that's actually a
relevant detail to the fact that he
became an archer because I think I
mentioned to you at one point that the
word sin is derived from a Greek word
amar kiya even though it sounds nothing
like that word and Hammar kiya is
actually a an archery term and it means
- it means to miss the bullseye and
that's a that's a lovely metaphor for
sin I think because it's associated so
tightly with the idea of of goal
direction and and aim you know because
there's an emetic Oracle idea that's
embedded in that in that image and that
is that you know a human being is
something that specifies a target which
we do all the time with their eyes by
the way I mean our eyes our target
specifying mechanisms you know we have
very precise central focal vision and we
use our focal vision to target the aim
of our behavior and so we are aiming
creatures there's our it's built right
into our Plouffe or body or we're built
on a hunting platform or aiming
creatures and we do that cognitively as
well as behaviorally and so as hunters
we take aim at things that we take aim
at moving targets and we're very good at
bringing them down and we've been doing
that for who knows how long millions of
years really even chimpanzees are
carnivorous by the way at least but from
them about 6 million years ago so we've
been hunting and aiming for a very very
long period of time and we still have
aims in our life right and that's how we
describe them what are you aiming at or
what are your aims what are your goals
what's your target it's all based on
not hunting metaphor and the fact that
Ishmael becomes an archer means that
he's someone who can take him at the
center of the bullseye and hit it
precisely and so that's an indication
that he's a good man right so and and I
suppose also part of the part of it
carries part of the narrative weight of
the story because of course he's
Abraham's son and you'd expect Abraham's
son to be someone who's very good at
taking aim and he dwelt in the
wilderness of paran and he could live
there and survive which is no trivial
thing and his mother took him a wife out
of the land of Egypt okay so that's the
story of Hagar and it's a fairly
straightforward story it's complex
emotionally but it doesn't and it and it
brings up the terrible theme of familial
catastrophe and the complications of
romantic and familial relationships and
all of that but it's really serves as a
pro drama to the next story which is the
one that's so complex and so difficult
to understand and it came to pass after
these things that God did tempt Abraham
which is a funny thing for God to do I
suppose and said unto Him Abraham and he
said behold Here I am and God said take
now thy son thine only son Isaac who the
lovest and at the end of the land of
Moriah and offer him there for a burnt
offering upon one of the mountains which
I will tell thee up
and Abraham rose up early in the morning
and saddled his ass and took two of his
young men with him and Isaac his son and
clave the wood for the burnt offering it
rose up and went unto the place of which
God had told him then on the third day
of journeying Abraham lifted up his eyes
and saw the place afar off the neighbor
hem said unto his young men abide ye ye
here with the ass and I and the lad will
go yonder and worship and come again to
you it's really one of the first times
that we've come across the word worship
if I remember correctly and that's a
very difficult word to contend with to
know is he if you like me or if you're
like me when I was a kid because I
haven't thought about this for a long
time it was never really obvious to me
why God would want to be worshipped you
know as to go to church and you offer up
your praise and thanks to God and you
say well really does that make a lot of
sense it's like why in the world is that
what he wants it's like it's almost like
you're you're you're you're kneeling
down in front of an ancient Middle
Eastern
you know tyrannical Emperor and and
vowing your submission and that never
sat well with me and I suppose it
doesn't sit well with many people and I
think that's because it's it's not the
proper way of conceptualizing it like
what happens when you see what Abraham
does continually and this seems to be
implicit in the use of the word worship
in this particular situation is that you
know he as we discussed he has an
adventure in his life that comes to an
end so there's an episode in this life
it comes to an end and then there's a
period of you might consider it re where
he reconstitutes himself to some degree
and it's that's when he makes the
sacrifices and it seems to me that it's
that reconstitution that constitutes the
worship the worship is something like
you know this is alluding back to my
original proposition that it's how you
act that's the issue and the worship is
the decision to enact the good in
whatever form it is that you can
conceptualize it as well as trying to
continually reconceptualize the good in
a manner that makes the good that you're
conceptualizing even that much better
right because when you start aiming the
probability that you're going to be
aiming in the right direction is very
low but
hypothetically as you aim and as you
practice and as you learn the target is
going to shift in front of your eyes and
you're going to be able to follow
whatever more clearly and so and that
seems to me and especially given the
context that this word is used in this
particular story is much more
appropriate interpretation of what
constitutes proper worship and I suppose
it's akin to the later Christian idea
that it's the imitation of Christ that's
the sacred duty of every Christian of
every Christian and every human being I
suppose insofar as that's an archetypal
idea an idea is something like well it's
the embodiment of the good that's the
issue and it's not your stated belief in
the good and you know when nature was
criticizing Christianity this is
actually one of the things that he
brought up as a major issue he said that
he believed Christianity had lost its
way because it had introduced a
confusion between stated belief which is
say your belief in the divinity of
Christ whatever it means if you state
that it isn't obvious what it means that
when you state that because it isn't
obvious what it would mean that you
believe it or even what it is that
you're believing in as far as Nietzsche
was concerned in some sense not only was
that beside the point it was dangerously
beside the point because it actually
allowed the Christian believer not to
adopt the moral burden that was actually
appropriate to the faith which was - and
this is I'm using a kind of a Union
concept here to manifest the archetype
within the confines of your own life
and that's to make the divine that your
relationship with the divine your
relationship with the transcendent an
infinite into something that's actually
realizable in the context of your own
life which is to say well you know
you're supposed to you're supposed to
again to act out the highest good of
which you're capable now that will
transform your life to some degree into
an archetypal adventure there's no way
around that because as you attempt to
climb a higher mountain let's say or to
aim at a higher target or something like
that then the things around you will
become increasingly dramatic and of
import that happens by necessity
obviously because if you're aiming at
something difficult and profound and
you're really working at it then your
life is going to become perhaps
increasingly difficult and profound but
that
might be okay you might that might be
exactly what you need as an antidote to
the implicit limitations that face you
as a human being so and I am the lad
will go yonder and worship and come
again to you now there's an implication
here too that it's a foreshadowing that
that Abraham offering up his son is
actually a form of worship and that's
that it's continuous with what he's
already done and well now I'm going to
read you some of the things that I've
written and then all return to this and
we'll see how that goes so life is
suffering that's clear there's no more
basic irrefutable truth it's basically
as we've seen what God tells out of and
Eve immediately before he kicks them out
of paradise quote unto the woman he said
I will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
thy conception in sorrow thou shalt
bring forth children and thy desire
shall be to thy husband and he shall
rule over thee and unto Adam he said
because you have hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and hast eaten of the
tree which I commanded thee saying thou
shalt not eat of it cursed is the ground
for thy sake in sorrow shalt thou eat of
it all the days of thy life thorns also
and thistles shall it bring forth to
thee and thou shalt eat the herb of the
field by the sweat of your brow you will
eat your food until you return to the
ground since from it you were taken for
dust you are and to dust you will return
rough you know and we've associated that
with with Adam and Eve's eyes opening
and then becoming self conscious and
discovering the future and becoming
fully aware and falling into history and
it seems to me to be a very realistic
existential portrayal of the predicament
of humankind what in the world should be
done about that the simplest most
obvious and most direct answer pursue
pleasure to follow your impulses live
for the moment do
expedient lie cheat steal deceive
manipulate but don't get caught in an
ultimately meaningless universe what
possible difference could it make and
this is by no means a new idea the fact
of life's tragedy in the suffering that
is part of it has been used to justify
the pursuit of immediate selfish
gratification for a very long time
now even reading young he often writes
as if before the rise of the conflict
between religion and science and which
culminated saying each his pronouncement
about the death of God that people lived
ensconce quite safely within a religious
conceptualization that have you´d their
life with meaning and that that was and
that was just the state of reality you
know but there's ancient writings that
makes it quite clear that the crisis of
faith that characterizes a modern people
were certainly far from unknown in the
past and here's one of those writings
this is from wisdom - the Revised
Standard Version short and sorrowful is
our life and there is no remedy when a
man comes to his end and no one has been
known to return from Hades because we
were born by mere chance and hereafter
we shall be as though we had never been
because the breath in our nostrils is
smoke and reason is just a spark kindled
by the beating of our hearts when it is
extinguished our body will turn to ashes
their spirit will dissolve like empty
air our name will be forgotten in time
and no one will remember our works our
life will pass away like the traces of a
cloud and be scattered like mist that is
chased by the Rays of the Sun and
overcome by its heat for our allotted
time is but the passing of a shadow and
there is no return from our death
because it is sealed up and no one turns
back come therefore let us enjoy the
good things that exist and make use of
the creation to the full as in youth let
us take our fill of costly wines and
perfumes and let no flower of spring
passes by let us crown ourselves with
rosebuds before they wither let none of
us fail
to share in our revelry everywhere let
us leave signs of enjoyment because this
is our portion and this is our Lord let
us oppress the righteous poor man
let us not spare the widow nor regard
the gray hairs of the agent but letter
might be our right for what is weak
proves itself to be useless it's an
amazing piece of writing you know it
starts with an announcement of the
rationale for nihilism and ends with the
justification for a fascist tyranny you
know and it's it's thousands of years
old it's it's a remarkable thing to see
and to be laid out so concisely the
pleasure of expediency may be fleeting
but it's pleasure nonetheless and that's
something to stack up against the terror
and pain of existence every man for
himself and the devil take the hindmost
as the old proverb has it why not simply
take everything you can get whenever the
opportunity arises why not determine to
live in that manner what's the
alternative and why should we bother
with it
our ancestors worked out very
sophisticated answers to such questions
but we still don't understand them very
well this is because they are in large
part still implicit manifest primarily
in ritual and myth and as of yet
incompletely articulated we act them out
represent them in stories but we're not
wise enough yet to formulate them
explicitly was still chimps in a troop
or wolves in a pack we know how to
behave we know who's who and why we've
learned that through experience our
knowledge has been shaped by our
interaction with others we've
established predictable routines and
patterns of behavior but we don't really
understand them or know where they
origin ated they've evolved over great
expanses of time no one was formulating
them explicitly at least not in the
dimmest reaches of the past even though
we've been telling each other how to act
forever one day however not so long ago
we woke up we were already doing
but we started noticing what we were
doing we started using our bodies as
devices to represent their own actions
we started imitating and dramatizing we
invented ritual we started acting out
our own experiences then we started to
tell stories we coated our observations
of our own drama in those stories in
this manner the information that was
first only embedded in our behavior
became represented in our stories but we
didn't and we still don't understand
what it all meant the biblical narrative
of paradise in the fall is one such
story fabricated by our collective
imagination working over the centuries
it provides a profound account of the
nature of being and points the way to a
mode of conceptualization and action
well matched to that nature in the
Garden of Eden prior to the dawn of
self-consciousness so goes the story
human beings were sinless our primordial
parents Adam and Eve walked with God
then tempted by the snake the first
couple ate from the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil discovered
death and vulnerability and turned away
from God mankind was exiled from
paradise and began its effortful mortal
existence the idea of sacrifice enter
soon afterwards beginning with the
account of Cain and Abel and developing
as we've seen through the Abrahamic
stories after much contemplation
struggling humanity learns that God's
favor could be gained and his wrath
averted through proper sacrifice and
also that bloody murder might be
motivated among those unwilling or
unable to succeed in this manner when
engaging in sacrifice our forefathers
began to act out what would be
considered a proposition if it were
stated in words that something better
might be attained in the future by
giving up something of value in the
present recall if you will that the
necessity for work is one of the curses
placed by God upon Adam and his
descendants in consequence of
original sin Adams waking to the
fundamental constraints of his being his
vulnerability his eventual death that's
equivalent to the discovery of the
future the future that's where you go to
die
hopefully not too soon your demise might
be staved off through work through the
sacrifice of the now to benefit later it
is for this reason among others no doubt
that the concept of sacrifice is
introduced in the biblical chapter
immediately following the drama of the
fall there's little difference between
sacrifice and work they're also both
uniquely human sometimes animals act as
if they're working but they're really
only following the dictates of their
natures beavers build dams they do so
because their beavers and beavers build
dams they don't think yeah but I'd
rather be on a beach in Mexico with my
girlfriend while they're doing it
prosaically such sacrifice work is delay
of gratification but that's a very
mundane phrase to describe something of
soul-shattering significance the
discovery that gratification could be
delayed was simultaneously the discovery
of time and with it causality long ago
in the dim mists of time we began to
realize that reality was structured as
if it could be bargained with
we learned that behaving properly now in
the present regulating our impulses
considering the plight of others could
bring rewards in the future in a time
and place that did not yet exist we
began to inhibit control and organize
our immediate impulses so that we could
stop interfering with other people and
our future selves doing so was
indistinguishable from organizing
society the discovery of the causal
relationship between our efforts today
and the quality of tomorrow motivated
the social contract the organization
that enables today's work to be stored
reliably mostly in the form of promises
from others
understanding is something that's often
acted out before it can be articulated
just as a child acts out what it means
to be mother or father before being able
to give a spoken account of what those
roles mean the idea the act of making a
ritual sacrifice to God was an early and
sophisticated enactment of the idea of
the usefulness of delay there's a long
conceptual journey between merely
feasting hungrily and learning to set
aside some extra meat smoked by the fire
for the end of the day or for someone
who isn't present it takes a long time
to learn to keep anything later for
yourself or to share it with someone
else and those are very much the same
thing as in the former case you're
sharing with your future self it's much
easier and far more likely to selfishly
it immediately Wolf's down everything in
sight there are similar long journeys
between every leap and sophistication
with regards to delay and its
conceptualization short term sharing
storing away from the for the future
representation of that storage in the
form of Records and later in the form of
currency and ultimately the saving of
money in a bank or other institution
some conceptualizations had to serve as
intermediaries or the full range of our
practices and ideas surrounding
sacrifice and work and their
representation could have never emerged
our ancestors acted out a drama a
literary fiction they personified the
force that governs fate as a spirit that
can be bargained with traded with as if
it were another human being and the
amazing thing is that it worked this was
in part because the future is largely
composed of other human beings often
precisely those who have watched and
evaluated and appraised the tiniest
details of your past behavior it's not
very far from that to God sitting above
on high tracking your every move and
writing it down for further reference in
a big book here's a productive symbolic
idea the future is a judgmental father
that's a good start
but two additional archetypal
foundational questions arose because of
the discovery of sacrifice of work both
have to do with the ultimate extension
of the logic of work which is sacrifice
now to gain later first question what
must be sacrificed small sacrifices
might be sufficient to small to solve
small singular problems but it's
possible that larger more comprehensive
sacrifices might solve an array of large
and complex problems all at the same
time that's harder but it might be
better adapting to the necessary
discipline of medical school for example
will fatally interfere with the licensee
estoppel giving that up as a sacrifice
but a physician can to quote George w
really put food on his family that's a
lot of trouble dispensed with over a
very long period of time so sacrifices
are necessary to improve the future and
larger sacrifices can be better second
question introduction we've already
established the basic principle
sacrifice will improve the future but
what's implied by that in the most
extreme and final of cases where does
that basic principle find its limits we
must ask to begin with what would be the
largest most effective most pleasing of
all possible sacrifices and then how
good might the best possible future be
if the most effective possible sacrifice
could be made the biblical story of Cain
and Abel Adam and Eve's sons immediately
follows the story of the expulsion from
paradise
as mentioned previously Cain and Abel
are really the first humans since their
parents were made directly by God and
not born in the standard manner Cain and
Abel live in history not in Eden they
must work they must make sacrifices to
please God and they do so with altar and
proper ritual but things get complicated
Abel's offerings please God but Cain's
do not Abel is rewarded many times over
but Cain is not it's not precisely clear
why although the text strongly hints
that Cain's heart is just not in it
maybe the quality of what Cain put
forward was low
maybe his spirit was begrudging or maybe
God was just feeling crabby and all of
this is realistic including the texts
vagueness of explanation not all
sacrifices are of equal quality
furthermore it often appears that
sacrifices of apparently high quality
are sometimes not rewarded with a better
future and it's not clear why why isn't
God happy what would have to change to
make him so these are difficult
questions and everyone asks them all the
time even if they don't notice asking
such questions is indistinguishable from
thinking the realization that pleasure
could be usefully forestalled dawned
with a difficulty that's almost
impossible to overstate such a
realization runs absolutely contrary to
our ancient fundamental animal instincts
which demand immediate satisfaction
particularly under conditions of
deprivation which are both inevitable
and commonplace and to complicate the
matter such delay only becomes useful
when civilization has stabilized itself
enough to guarantee the existence of the
delayed reward if everything you say
will be destroyed or worse stolen
there's no point saving it's for this
reason that a wolf will down 20 pounds
of raw meat in a single meal he isn't
thinking man I hate it when I binge I
should save some of this for next week
there's a developmental progression from
animal to human it's wrong no doubt in
the details but it's sufficiently
correct for our purposes and theme first
there's excess food large carcasses
mammoths or other massive herbivores
might provide that way a lot of mammoths
maybe all of the
with a large animal there's some left
for later after a kill
that's accidental at first but
eventually the utility of for later
starts to be appreciated some
provisional notion of sacrifice develops
at the same time if I leave some now
even if I want it now I won't have to be
hungry later that provisional notion
then develops to the next level if I
leave some for later I won't have to go
hungry and neither will those I care for
and then to the next level I can't
possibly eat all this mammoth but I
can't store the rest for too long either
maybe I should feed some to other people
maybe they'll remember and feed me some
of their mammoths when they have some
and I have none then I'll get some
mammoths now and some mammoths later
that's a good deal and maybe those I'm
sharing with will come to trust me more
generally maybe then we could trade
forever in such a manner
mammoth becomes future mammoth and
future mammoth becomes personal
reputation that's the emergence of the
social contract to share does not mean
to give away something you value and get
nothing back that's only instead what
every child who refuses to share is
afraid that it means to share means
properly to initiate the process of
trade a child who can't share who can't
trade can't have any friends because
having friends is a form of trade
Benjamin Franklin once suggested that a
newcomer to a neighbourhood asked a new
neighbor to do him or her a favor
citing an old maxim he that has once
done you a kindness will be more ready
to do you another than he whom you
yourself have obliged in Franklin's
opinion asking something for someone
asking someone for something not too
extreme obviously was the most useful
and immediate invitation to social
interaction such asking allowed the
neighbor to show him or herself as a
good person at first encounter it also
meant the neighbor could now ask the
newcomer for a favor in return because
of the debt incurred
in that manner both parties could
overcome their natural hesitancy and
mutual fear of the stranger it's better
to have something rather than nothing
it's better yet to generously share the
something you have it's even better than
that however to become widely known for
generous sharing that's something that
lasts that's something that's reliable
and at this point in abstraction we can
observe how the groundwork for the
conceptions of reliable honest and
generous have been laid the basis for an
articulated morality has been put in
place the productive truthful sharer is
the prototype for the good citizen and
the good man we can see in this manner
how from the simple notion that
leftovers are a good idea the highest
moral principles might emerge it's as if
something like this happened as humanity
developed first were the endless tens or
hundreds of thousands of years prior to
the emergence of written history and
drama during this time the twin
practices of delay and exchange began to
emerge slowly and painfully then they
became represented in metaphorical
abstraction as rituals and tales of
sacrifice told in a manner such as this
it's as if there's a powerful figure in
the sky who sees all and is judging you
giving up something you value seems to
make them happy and you want to make
them happy because all hell breaks loose
if you don't so practice sacrificing and
sharing until you become expert at it
and things will go well for you
no one said any of this at least not so
plainly and directly but it was implicit
in the practice and then in the stories
action came first as it had to as the
animals we once were could act but could
not think implicit unrecognized value
came first as the actions that preceded
thought
bodied value but did not make that value
explicit people watched the successful
succeed and the unsuccessful fail for
thousands and thousands of years we
thought it over and we drew a conclusion
the successful among us delay
gratification the successful among us
bargained with the future a great idea
began to emerge taking ever more clearly
articulated form and ever more clearly
articulated stories what's the
difference between the successful and
the unsuccessful for the successful
sacrifice things get better as the
successful practice their sacrifices the
questions become increasingly precise
and simultaneously broader what's the
greatest possible sacrifice for the
greatest possible good and the answer
has become increasingly deeper and
profound the god of Western tradition
like so many gods requires sacrifice
we've already examined why but sometimes
he goes even further he demands not only
sacrifice but the sacrifice of precisely
what is loved best this is most starkly
portrayed and most confusingly evident
in the story of Abraham and Isaac
Abraham beloved of God long wanted the
son and God promised him exactly that
after many delays and under the
imperative possible conditions of old
age and a long barren wife but not so
long afterward when the miraculously
born Isaac is still a child God turns
around and in apparently barbaric
fashion demands that his faithful
servant offer his son as a sacrifice
the story ends happily God sends an
angel to stay Abraham's obedient hand
and accepts a ram and Isaac stead that's
a good thing it doesn't really address
the issue at hand
why was God's going further necessary
why does he why his life impose such
demands
we'll start our analysis with the truism
stark self-evident and understated
sometimes things do not go well that
seems to have much to do with the
terrible nature of the world with its
plagues and its famines and its
tyrannies and its betrayals but here's
the rub
sometimes when things are not going well
it's not the world that it's the cause
the cause is instead that which is most
valued why because the world is revealed
to an in terment degree through the
template of your values if the world you
are seeing is not the world you want
therefore it's time to examine your
values it's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions it's time to let
go it might even be time to sacrifice
what you love best so that you can
become who you might become instead of
staying who you are something valuable
given up ensures fused future prosperity
something valuable sacrifice pleases the
Lord what is most valuable and best
sacrificed or what is at least
emblematic of that a choice cut of meat
the best animal in a flock a most valued
possession what's above even not
something intensely personal and painful
to give up that symbolized perhaps in
God's insistence on circumcision as part
of Abraham sacrificial routine what's
beyond that what pertains more closely
to the whole person rather than the part
what constitutes the ultimate sacrifice
for the gain of the ultimate prize it's
a close race between child and self the
sacrifice of the mother offered her
child to the world is exemplified for
example by Michelangelo's great
sculpture the Pieta Michelangelo crafted
Mary contemplating her son crucified in
ruins so she's sitting most of you know
the sculpture she's sitting and the body
of her son is in her arms
adults on and it's broken and he's been
destroyed and it's a very beautiful but
very tragic work of genius work of
genius level representation
Michelangelo crafted Mary contemplating
her son crucified and rude it's her
fault it was through her that he entered
the world and it's great drama of being
is it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world every woman asks herself
that question some say no they have
their reasons Mary answers yes
voluntarily knowing full well what's to
come as do all mothers if they allow
themselves to see it's an act of supreme
courage when it's undertaken voluntarily
in turn Mary's son Christ offers himself
to God and the world to betrayal torture
and death to the very point of despair
on the cross where he cries out those
terrible words my God my God why hast
thou forsaken me that is the archetypal
story of the man who gives his all for
the sake of the better who offers up his
life for the advancement of being who
allows God's will to become manifest
fully within the confines of a single
mortal life that is the model for the
Honorable man in Christ case however as
he sacrifices himself God his father is
simultaneously sacrificing his son it's
for this reason that the Christian
sacrificial drama of son and self is
archetypal it's a story at the limit
where nothing more extreme nothing
greater can be imagined that's the very
definition of archetypal that's the core
of what constitutes religious pain and
suffering define the world of that there
can be no doubt sacrifice can hold pain
and suffering in abeyance to a greater
or lesser degree and greater sacrifices
can do that more effectively than lesser
of that two there can be no doubt
everyone holds this knowledge in their
soul thus the person who wishes to
alleviate suffering who wishes to
defy the flaws in being who wishes to
bring about the best of all possible
futures who wants to create heaven on
earth will make the greatest of
sacrifices of self and child of
everything that is loved to live a life
am dat the good he will forego
expediency he will pursue the path of
ultimate meaning and he will in that
manner bring salvation to the ever
desperate world on the third day Abraham
lifted up his eyes and saw the place far
off it's not an accident also that it's
in a mountain right because a mountain
is something you have to climb and you
have to climb to the pinnacle of a
mountain and the mountain is upright and
the mountain stretches up to heaven and
it's a long journey to specify the right
place on the highest pinnacle and and
that's symbolic because of course it's a
pinnacle that you're always trying to
reach just like you're always trying to
aim you're always trying to climb upward
at least that's the theory depends to
some degree of course on your definition
of upward and Abraham said to his young
men abide here with the ass and I and
the lad will go yonder and worship and
come to you again and Abraham took the
wood of the burnt offering and laid it
upon Isaac his son and he took the fire
in his hand and a knife and they went
both of them together and Isaac spake
unto Abraham his father and said My
father and he said here am I my son and
he said Behold the fire in the wood but
where is the lamb for a burnt offering
and Abraham said my son God will provide
himself a lamb for a burnt offering
so they went both of them together and
they came to the place which God had
told him of and Abraham built an altar
there and laid the wood in order and
bound Isaac his son and laid him on the
altar upon the wood and Abraham
stretched forth his hand and took the
knife to slay his son and the angel of
the Lord called unto him out of heaven
and said Abraham and he said here am I
an angel said lay not thine hand upon
the lad neither do thou anything unto
him for now I know that thou fearest God
seeing thou hast not withheld thy son an
only son from me
when I was answering the questions last
night at this Q&A this guy asked me this
question he said that he had parents who
were desperate anti-social alcoholic
addicted friendless and that they didn't
want him to leave their home he was the
only relationship they had but that was
of he was the only relationship they had
and he asked what he should do and I
told him that he should leave and the
reason for that is that you have a moral
obligation as a parent to encourage your
child to go out into the world right and
to be whoever they can be to be the best
they can possibly be and in doing that
you're offering you're encouraging them
to pursue the good you're sacrificing
them to the good you're not keeping them
for yourself selfishly you're telling
them that they can go out and live their
life and live it properly and and that's
the parallel to the idea of the
sacrifice of Isaac as far as I can tell
you don't want for your son what it is
that you want for him you want for your
son what would be best for him and for
the world and you let go in precise
proportion to your desire to have that
happen you know the psychoanalyst the
great psychoanalyst I say the
psychoanalyst I think this is actually
Freud's dictum but I'm not certain of
that he said the good mother fails
which is a bit a brilliant observation
because when you have an infant do you
do everything for the infant because the
infant can do nothing for him or herself
but as the infant matures and is
increasingly capable of doing things for
him or herself then you pull back right
you pull
back and everytime the child develops
the ability to do something you allow
them or encourage them to do it and you
don't interfere you know so if your
child is struggling getting dressed well
obviously there's some times that you
help them but mostly you let them learn
so that they can know how to do it in
the future that's better for you and
it's certainly better for them there's a
rule if you're working with the elderly
in an old-age home and the rule is
something like don't do anything for any
of the for any of the guests let's say
that they can do for themselves because
you compromise their independence and so
as a mother you pull back and you pull
back and you let your child hit him or
herself against the world and you fail
to protect them but by failing to
protect them you encourage and ennoble
them to the point where you're no longer
necessary now they may still want to see
you and it would be wonderful if that
was the case but the point is is that
you're supposed to remove yourself from
the equation by encouraging your child
to be the best possible person that
person can be and you sacrifice your
desires all of your desires to that your
personal desires even your desires for
your child in relationship to you
because you want them to move forward
into the world as a light right as a
light on a hill that's what you want if
you have any sense and so you don't get
to keep your children at home because
you need them now I'm talking generally
obviously and there are circumstances
under which families make their own
idiosyncratic decisions and I'm not
trying to dam everyone with a with a
casual gesture you know but the point is
still strong that the good father is
precisely someone who is willing to
sacrifice his child to the ultimate good
that's dramatized in this story you know
and it's brutal but the world is a
brutal place and much wisdom comes out
of catastrophe and this is an indication
of how much catastrophe our ancestors
had to plow through had to work through
in order to generate the sub structure
for the conceptions of freedom even that
we have to
they for freedom and the good and that's
how the story appears to me now I think
there's more to it I think if there has
to be more to it it lays the groundwork
at least in the Christian context for
the eventual emergence of Christ as I
alluded to in my reading that story
obviously has to be unpacked and
unpacked and unpacked just like it has
been for the last two thousand years
it's also an indication here of well I
would say the transmutation of sacrifice
into an increasingly psychological form
which is a development that we've
tracked all the way through the Old
Testament up to this particular point
first acted out then represented in
ritual those would be the rituals of
sacrifice then laid out in story then
turned into a psychological phenomena so
that now we're capable of making
sacrifices in abstraction right to
conceptualize a future that we want to
let go of the things that are stopping
us from moving forward and to free
ourselves from the chains of our
original preconceptions and that's laid
out in these old stories as the optimal
path way of being and there's a
philosopher of science named Karl Popper
very sensible and down-to-earth person
who was talking about thinking and its
nature and he was thought about thinking
in a Darwinian fashion he said the
purpose of thinking is to let your
thoughts die instead of you it's a
brilliant notion and so the idea is
something like you can conjure up a
representation of yourself you can
conjure up a variety of potential
representations of yourself in the
future you can lay out how those future
representations of yourself are likely
to prevail or fail you can call the
potential use in the future that will
fail and then you can embody the ones
that will succeed you do that well
simultaneously conjuring up a
representation of your current state and
determining for yourself because of your
undue suffering which elements of your
pathetic being need to be given up so
that you can move forward into that
future
and the goal what is it that you're
aiming at with that work and not
sacrifice that's the ultimate question
it's the question I was trying to
address in that writing what is it that
you're trying to do when you're trying
to improve the future we believe that
the future can be improved we believe
that it can be improved as a consequence
of our sacrificial work and so once
again what are the limitations what are
the limits to that what are the
necessary limits to that I would say we
don't know I would say as well that
that's actually something that the
entire corpus of biblical stories is
trying desperately to articulate to
figure out and articulate right we we
conjured up this remarkable idea the
future exists we can see it even though
it's only potential we can adjust our
behavior in the present in order to
maximize our probability of success in
the future
how best to do that well the idea is
something like don't hesitate to offer
the ultimate sacrifice if you want the
future to turn out ultimately well now
obviously that idea is closed in
metaphysical speculation and religious
imagery but it still remains an
intensely practical issue right what is
it that you could contract for let's say
if you were willing to give up
everything about you that's weak and
unworthy
the there's a there's a continual hints
of that in the Old Testament right
because what happens with Noah
of course is that he establishes the
proper covenant with God the proper
contract with being let's say and
thrives as a consequence and the
neighborhood does the same thing there's
a strong intimation that that's how the
world is set right now that idea
develops and magnifies as the stories
progress into something like into
something like the concept of heaven on
earth the notion being that the proper
sacrificial attitude produces a
psychological state and then the social
state that's a manifestation of that
attitude that decreases the probability
that the world will Carine into hell and
increases the probability that people
will live high-quality meaningful
private lives in a society that's
balanced and capable of supporting that
and none of that seems to me to be
questionable really I also don't think
it's anything that people don't actually
know you know people have told me many
times that when they listen to me talk
they are hearing things that they
already know knew but didn't know how to
say it's something like that and this is
one of those things that I think is
exactly like that I mean I think it's at
the very core of our moral knowledge and
which is our behavioral knowledge and
our perceptual knowledge I mean let's
get this straight
moral knowledge is no trivial matter
it's knowledge about how it is that you
orient yourself in the world there's no
more profoundly necessary form of
knowledge
oh it's predicated on on something
that's exactly like this we know that we
have to make sacrifices we know that we
have to omit what's good so then why
isn't that we don't aim at what's best
and make the sacrifices that are
necessary in order to bring that into
play I think it seems to me that in some
sense that's self-evident the question
is why we don't do it but there's
answers to that too already in
material that we've covered life is hard
and it hurts people it's ripe with
limitation and some of its arbitrary and
it's no wonder and some of its unjust
and some of it's worse some of its
malevolent which is even worse than
something I haven't talked about at all
in this lecture it's not surprising that
that combination of vicissitude can turn
people against being but I think even
when that happens and even when people
have the kind of history that if they
revealed to you you would say well it's
no wonder you turned out that way the
people who turn out that way still know
that it's wrong they still know that
however deep their own suffering however
arbitrary their own suffering however
much that's caused by the malevolence of
others as well as the tragedy of
existence that that does not in any way
justify their turning away from the good
and I believe everyone knows that I
believe that they know it implicitly
even if they don't allow themselves to
know it explicitly and I believe that if
they violate that idea then they violate
themselves and that they end up in
Kane's position which is the position of
the man who's been given a punishment
that is too great to bear an angel said
[Applause]
lay not thine hand upon the loud now to
do without anything unto him for now I
know that thou fearest God seeing thou
hast not withheld thy son thine only son
from me
and Abraham lifted up his eyes and
looked and behold behind him a ram
caught in a thicket by his thorns by his
horns and Abraham went and took the RAM
and offered him up for a burnt offering
instead of his son and Abraham called
the name of that place Jehovah Jireh as
it is said to this day in the mount of
the Lord it shall be seen and the angel
of the Lord called unto Abraham out of
heaven the second time and said by
myself have I sworn saith the Lord for
because thou has done this thing and has
not withheld thy son thine only son that
in blessing I will bless thee and in
multiplying I will multiply thy seed as
the stars of the heaven and as the sand
which is upon the sea shore and thy seed
shall possess the gates of his gate of
his enemies and in thy seed shall all
the nations of the earth be blessed
because thou hast obeyed my voice
so Abraham returned unto his young men
and they rose up and went together to
Beersheba and Abraham dwelt at Beersheba
and it came to pass after these things
that it was told Abraham saying he hold
Milka
she has also borne children unto thy
brother Nahor and Sarah was a hundred
and seven and twenty years old those
were the years of the life of Sarah and
Sarah died in quor'toth Arba the same as
Hebron in the land of Canaan and Abraham
came to mourn for Sarah and a weeper
well I don't exactly know what to do now
because that
[Applause]
I'll review what we've what we've
covered and then I'll bring this to a
close we can have some more questions
than would be usual tonight so what have
we established by this point the stories
that have been revealed so far are
something like they contain the idea
that there's something divine that's
analogous to the human capacity for
communication and attention that's at
the it operates at the genesis of being
itself that's the initial account in the
Old Testament it's an account that
places the role of Spirit centrally in
the in the nature of being now I'm not
exactly sure what to make of that
because in some ways I'm is
materialistically oriented as modern
people typically are but the stories
make sense to me in many ways the idea
that there's something world creating
about human consciousness and that
that's akin in some sense to the divine
force that called order out of chaos at
the beginning of time
seems to me to be a very powerful
metaphysical idea and it also seems to
me to be an idea that is immovable at
the foundation of Western culture
because our entire legal system our
society our expect mutual expectations
all of that are conditioned to the final
degree by our presupposition that each
of us has an intrinsic value that
transcends the local conditions of our
being and it's with that presupposition
that we've been able to establish the
society
that functions a society that functions
and functions well and it has its
current characterization and that's a
nun it's an unlikely occurrence and it's
a non-trivial reality and I don't see
any way out of that way out of that
conclusion I don't see anything that
that can easily be replaced with and so
god calls being into order into being
out of chaos at the beginning of time
and the tributes to human beings the
same essential capacity then we turn to
Adam and Eve in the garden and they're
unconscious by all appearances allied
tightly with God but unconscious they
don't seem aware of the future
they don't seem aware of themselves they
don't seem aware of their own
vulnerability they make the fatal error
of having their eyes open they discover
their own vulnerability they also
discover their capacity for evil we
reviewed that to some degree
what's the association because it's the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
the fruit of which they eat what's the
association between the discovery of
vulnerability and the emergence of moral
knowledge it's something like as far as
I can tell that you actually don't know
how to be evil or to be good until
you're actually aware consciously of
your own vulnerability because the
essence of evil is the exploitation of
vulnerability perhaps for the sake of
that exploitation and I can't understand
how to hurt someone until I know exactly
how I can be hurt myself and I can't
understand how I can be hurt myself
until I become cognizant of my mortal
limitations until I understand what
brings me pain until I understand the
suffering that goes along with my mortal
limitations my my inevitable death and
the suffering that goes along with that
and with the with the accrual of the
knowledge of mortality and good and evil
Adam and Eve are cast out of paradise
and history begins and that seems right
to me because I don't think that history
did begin before human beings became
self conscious
so there's something about that that's
right if his
three doesn't really begin until people
become aware of the future history
doesn't really begin until until people
work and start to build right we still
live we would still be ensconced in
essentially an animal existence until
we're aware of the future and start to
buttress herself against it start to
wear clothing start to build buildings
start to make cities all in all in
consequence of having become aware of
the fact that we're fragile and that the
future is a dangerous place so that
seems to me to be existentially correct
and then we have the story of Cain and
Abel brilliantly placed immediately
afterwards and so those are the two
first two people in history essentially
and they make sacrifices so that goes
along with the idea of the discovery
worked and necessity of work and the
discovery of the future and then exactly
what you'd expect would happen one
segment of mankind let's say makes the
sacrifices properly and prevails in the
other segment makes the sacrifices
improperly and fails and that's
perfectly reasonable given what you see
around you because that's what seems to
happen all the time and then more
interestingly I would say that the
sacrificial failure produces
embitterment right and that embedment
produces a hatred for being and a desire
for revenge that seems perfectly
appropriate when I look at people who
are bitter and who want revenge it's
generally because their sacrificial
efforts have failed now I'm loathe to
say that that's a matter of their own
doing although sometimes it clearly is
the embittered and vengeful complained
to God and blame him for the structure
of existence you know I read about the
Columbine massacre and the kids who
undertook it that'll make your hair
stand on end if you want to read
something that will really disturb you
reading Erich Harris's writings will
really disturb you no matter how much
you know about human beings reading
Erich Harris's writings will disturb you
and Harris's Kane you know
he says it straightforwardly he hates
human beings hates being itself he would
destroy everything if it was within his
power to do that and of course him and
his colleague were motivated to produce
far more carnage than they managed that
day what was successful was only a
fraction of what they had planned and
and Harris said very straightforwardly
that he was that he had set himself up
as the judge of being and that it lacked
all utility in his eyes human beings
certainly should all be did all be
removed from the face of existence
because of their pathology and the
fundamental horrors of being itself so
there's nothing in the Cain and Abel
story that isn't real it's real and Kane
complains to God as people will when
their dreams are dashed and then it's
goes for people who don't believe in God
- it doesn't really matter you know it's
harder I suppose if you're atheistic to
figure out who to blame but that doesn't
mean that the sentiment well it doesn't
mean that the sentiment is any different
right the same drama is being enacted
you shake your fist at the structure of
being rather than at God himself but it
doesn't make any difference except in
the details so God responds to Cain and
tells him that he's got no right to
judge being before he gets his
sacrificial house in order and even
worse he says that Cain is the architect
of his own downfall and the invited
catastrophe in his own house into his
own house willingly and entered into a
creative union with it and therefore
brought about his own demise and it's
that additional self-knowledge and you
can imagine to you know imagine that
you're in you're facing your life you're
facing the failures of your life and
let's say that you've had a failed life
and you're bitter about that and then
you meditate upon it and you think why
has this come about and then you think
well perhaps I did something wrong you
know when Alexander Solzhenitsyn wrote
The Gulag Archipelago which is the book
that detailed the catastrophes of the
Soviet you
and help bring it down it is one part of
that book that just struck me so so
viciously when I read it he he was in
the car in the GU leg and he was there
for a very long time and he said that he
observed a variety of people in the
camps who he really admired they were
rare
they were usually religious believers in
his in his experience who were not
participating in the pathology of the
camp's at all period no matter what he
said he learned a lot from watching
those people he had a hard time
believing that they even existed that
they could even exist but he said that
one of the things that he was brought to
as a consequence of watching those
people live their contract with goodness
out even under the most horrifying of
conditions was that it was possible that
he himself was responsible for his
position in the camp now it's a very
dangerous line of argumentation you know
because who wants to be the one who
blames the victim for the catastrophe
you know you have to be very careful
when you walk down that road but
Solzhenitsyn was speaking about himself
and he said well he was a communist you
know and he arrogantly and forthrightly
moved the movement out into the world
and had not fully gone over his life
with a fine-tooth comb to find out what
mistakes he had made that brought him so
low but his contention eventually was
that part of the reason that he ended up
where he ended up was because he and
many others had completely forfeited
their relationship with the truth and
allowed their society to degenerate into
deceit and tyrannical catastrophe
without mounting sufficient opposition
and so he decided when he was in the
camps to straighten himself out bit by
bit and that culminated in the
production of the Gulag Archipelago in
that book really demolished once and for
all any moral credibility that the
communist totalitarian systems had left
and so one man in the depths of
catastrophe
who
and through good example at least in
part to stop lying produced a book
eventually the demolished the foundation
of the very system that had imprisoned
him and that is really worth thinking
about that's one example of the absolute
grandeur of the human soul and the
capacity for transformation that it has
when let loose properly on the world so
let's say you're conceptualizing your
own failure you know and you meditated
on it and you come to the conclusion
that God forced Cain to pay not only
have things not been going very well for
you but it's actually your fault and not
only that you brought it on yourself and
not only that you knew it all the time
well then you might think you'll wake up
and fly right right you'll get your
wings in order and fly right but there's
no reason to assume that at all and
that's not what happens to Cain that
just makes him more bitter right and you
can understand that if you think about
it just for a second it's like bad
enough when something horrible happens
to you but then to have to swallow the
additional pill right have to take in
the information that you could have done
something different
it was avoidable and you knew it at the
time and you decided to do it anyways
and I think people are in that situation
a lot more often than ever anyone is
willing to admit you know you have that
little voice in the back of your head
that says don't do it and you override
it and you know it's arrogance that
makes you override it it's always
arrogance you know it always warns you
to always arrogance yeah I can get away
with it it's like no you can't I don't
think you ever get away with anything
so and maybe your experience has taught
you different but my suspicions are it
hasn't and if you think it has well the
other shoe hasn't yet dropped so Cain
doesn't take the opportunity to let
God's wisdom reorient his character and
that that could have been outcome he
could have got down on his knees so to
speak and said oh my oh my god I've been
wrong all along I've been living
improperly I've been making the wrong
sacrifices Abel deserves everything he
has I got exactly what was coming to me
you know could I possibly now Street
myself out and and
and and and live in repentance and
improve my position but that's not what
he did at all he said all right fair
enough I get it it's like I'm going to
go after the thing I most admire and I'm
going to destroy it
and I'm going to do that despite its
cost to me and I'm going to do that just
to spite the creator of being that's
exactly what Paris did at Columbine it's
exactly what he says in fact it is
uncanny writings it's why the mass
murderers always shoot themselves
afterwards not before because you might
wonder if you're so upset with the
structure of being why you don't just
commit suicide in your basement why do
you have to go out and mass murder
before you top it off with a gun to your
forehead well you don't make the point
as effectively if you just commit
suicide in your basement it's like well
I'm I life means nothing to me
but neither does anyone else's and
neither does the structure of being
itself and I'll take all my revenge as
much as I possibly can and then just to
show you how little I care I'll cap
myself off at the end and I would say
also people say all the time I don't
understand how that could happen it's
like I don't believe that I think an
hour of thought of real thought real
thought about your darkest feelings
about existence itself illuminates the
pathway to that sort of behavior quite
clearly I think if you I mean I might be
wrong I might be a darker person than
most and it's certainly okay okay
well at least I think there are plenty
of people out there who are sufficiently
dark to know exactly what I mean what
I'm saying these things and I would also
say that if it doesn't leap to your
understanding how that pathway might be
illuminated then you need to know a lot
more about yourself than you actually
know now because whatever you might say
about someone like Eric Harris he was a
human being too
you know there's this idea in the New
Testament that Christ was he who took
the sins of the world unto himself it's
a very complicated idea but part of it
part of it part of it is associated with
the idea that he met the devil in the
desert as well to take the sins of
mankind onto yourself as to understand
that within you dwells exactly the same
spirit that commit the atrocities that
Columbine or that ran the camps at
Auschwitz and to actually understand
that that's part and parcel of your
makeup and then to take responsibility
for it and I think that in the aftermath
of the terrible 20th century that's what
we're left with we are left with the
necessity to take responsibility for the
most terrible aspects of ourselves and
that way perhaps we can stop those
terrible things from happening again
that also means you know that you don't
look for the you don't look for the what
would you call it the purveyor of
malevolence outside yourself right it
isn't someone else even though sometimes
it's someone else you know you know what
I mean it's like there are identifiable
perpetrators but that's not precisely
the point the point is something more
like that the proper place for the
encapsulation of that malevolence at
least the proper place to start is
within the confines of your own
existence and then perhaps within the
confines of your family and that way
you're not a danger to those that you
miss apprehend as malevolent and evil
because you won't get your aim right to
begin with you'll identify them
improperly and you'll take your revenge
in a manner that allows you to omit your
own responsibility to act out your
unconscious desire for revenge and to
move the world just that much closer to
help also Cain kills Abel and then Cain
gives rise to his descendants one of
whom is the person who's the first
artificer in weapons of war and then
comes the flood right which seems
perfectly miraculously reasonable to me
because what those stories do it's so
amazing that the story of Cain and Abel
segues into the story of the flood
because it is the case that the
catastrophes that beset society can best
be conceptualized as the spread of
individual pathology into the social
world and the envy what would you call
these the magnification of that
pathology to the point where everything
comes apart and I truly believe that if
you familiarize yourself with the last
hundred years of history that that's the
conclusion that you would derive and the
people who are most wise that I've read
who commented on that say the same thing
over and over which is the key to the
prevention of the horrors of Auschwitz
and the gulag in the future is the
reconstruction of the individual soul at
level of each individual and that's a
terrible message because it puts the
burden on you but it's an amazing
message because it also means that you
could be the source of the process that
stops that catastrophe and malevolence
from ever emerging again and you know
it's hard for me to imagine that you
have anything that could possibly be
better to do with the time that you have
left well then we see Noah who walks
with God and who's generations are in
order right which means that he's
entered this contract with the good
let's say that has the protective
function of the ark he's put his family
together and he can ride out the worst
catastrophe and he's actually our
ancestor right so interesting it's that
these people who get their act together
properly and make a contract with the
good are constantly presented as the
genuine ancestors of mankind and that's
a really positive element of the story
as well and it's one I believe because
well it hasn't been easy for us to get
here you know we are the descendants of
the great heroes of the past and if you
took all those heroes and you and you
and you
and you told their stories and you
distilled their stories into a single
story maybe you'd have a story like the
story of Noah or the story of Abraham
you know the story of the successful the
story of our forefathers you know I'm
not the cancer on the planet that
certain people tend to think that we are
and so the goal is to be one of the
people like that and there isn't
anything better that can possibly be
done and the alternative is something
like hell and so Noah rides out the
storm and that's what everyone wants
because you want to ride out the storm
you don't want to be happy because
that'll just happen if it does or if it
doesn't but you definitely want to
constitute yourself so that you can ride
out the storm because the storm is
always coming and so then you're
fortified against the worst and that's
what you want because well the best you
can handle the worst you have to prepare
yourself for and then we see the same
thing repeated in the story of Abraham
essentially right Abraham makes this
contract with the good and constantly
renews it that's
cough ice and his worship he constantly
renews it and he has the adventures that
are sufficiently typical of the
adventures of a human being who's alive
and engaging in the world right he he
bumps himself up against all the horrors
of existence and yet the story is told
in such a manner that reveals that his
primary ethical commitment to the
overarching good is sufficient to
protect him against the vicissitudes of
existence well that's an optimistic
story and as a pessimistic person I
appreciate an optimistic story that's
believable and the great demands placed
on Abraham it's not as if this just
comes to him as a gift he has to be
willing to sacrifice whatever is
necessary in order to maintain that
contract and so that seems to me to be
realistic there's no reason to assume
that life isn't so difficult that it
actually demands the best from you that
it's actually structured in that manner
and that if the you are willing to
reveal the best in you in response to
the vicissitudes of life that you might
actually prevail and you might actually
set things straight around you and law
and what if that was true that would be
a remarkable thing and I can't see how
it cannot be true and I can't see that
it's not stamped on the soul of everyone
who's conscious I think we all know this
perfectly well although the stories
remind us you know Plato Socrates
believed that all knowledge was
remembering you know he believed that
the soul before birth had all knowledge
and lost it at birth and then experience
reminded the soul of what it already
knew and there's something about that
that's really true because you're not
just a creature that emerged 30 years
ago or 40 years ago you're you're the
inheritor of three and a half billion
years worth of biological engineering
right you have your nature stamped
deeply inside of you far more deeply
than we
any of us realize and when you come
across these great stories these
reminders they're a reminder of how to
be properly and they echo in your soul
because the structure is already there
the external stories are manifestations
of the internal reality and then they're
a call to that unter internal reality to
reveal itself well then we come to the
end of the Abrahamic stories least this
section of them with Sarah's death and
Abraham is called upon to make the
supreme sacrifice and interestingly not
because he's willing to make the supreme
sacrifice he actually doesn't have to
and that's an interesting thing as well
because I believe that it's reasonable
from a psychological perspective to
point out that the more willing you are
for example to face death perhaps the
less likely it is that you're going to
have to face it at least in an ignoble
manner and so with that then we'll bring
this 12 part series to a close
you know I think that applause is for
everyone and I hate to say that because
it sounds so new agey ha ha ha but you
know it really does it really does seem
to me that this is a participatory
exercise you know and that and that it
would not be possible for me to go
through these stories without having you
here to listen and so and I always think
when talking to a crowd that it's a
dialogue you know it's a dialogue you
said and you listen and you've all
listened and and and thank God for that
you know and that gives me a chance to
think and it gives me a chance to watch
and it gives me a chance to interact
because you know you're emblematic of of
humanity at large I suppose that's one
way of thinking about it and for me to
be able to craft what I'm saying so that
it has an impact on all of you here also
means that I can simultaneously craft it
so that it has an impact that in
principle can reach far beyond this
place and so you know I'm hoping that
I'm really hoping that one of the things
that can start to happen with this at
least is that we can put our culture
back on its firm foundation because it's
something that's desperately needed and
in order to do that we have to
understand both the evil and the
nobility of the human soul and that's
like--that's that's a fundamental truth
you know and I don't think you can get
to the nobility without a soldier and
through the evil I really don't believe
that at all it's no place for the naive
to go that's for sure but anyways I
would like to thank you as you thanked
me for your close and careful attention
and your support during all of this it's
been a really a remarkable experience
it's certainly sort of developed beyond
my my dreams so
on to the questions hi dr. Peterson it
appears to me from this series and from
the biblical stories themselves that the
emphasis of the stories is the utmost
importance of the fool for the
maintenance and adaptation of being or
society the figure will lunge headfirst
in the uncharted territory explicitly
aware of the danger and risk of loss and
confronting what cannot be understood
but unafraid and with the zeal and that
the dangers of ideological possession
just as much are just as much of a
concern as that individuals are
unwilling and perhaps unable to form an
opinion and take a stance one way or
another when confronted with a fork in
the road or a decision that must be made
you've seen this apathy apathy
throughout the universities as I have
too in the public schooling system my
question is how can one model being the
fool to plunge into the unknown and
publicly fall on your face in pursuit of
learning in a way that clearly
demonstrates the urgency and utility of
the fool well there isn't any difference
between the pool and someone whose
courageous right from an archetypal
perspective and I mean Abraham is a fool
obviously when he starts his his
adventures I mean the story lays it out
in that manner he's far too old to be
leaving home for example he's a late
bloomer you know and and then he has he
has a lot of catastrophic adventures
along the way and certainly you could
imagine that had you encountered him
when he first encountered the famine in
the land of strangers when he first went
out that the idea that he had he had
followed his misguided intuitions would
have been self-evident but in the
Abrahamic stories there is this call to
get out and do and that's it and the
thing is is that you know one of the
things I've learned to put it to make it
concretely is that like I've done a lot
of different things in my life and every
time I did a new thing I was a fool I
did it badly I was an imposter right and
and and because I when you first start
to do something you don't know what
you're doing but that that's okay that's
an acceptance of your vulnerability
right
and your ignorance that's humility in
some sense the willingness to be a fool
in a nude in the land of strangers
that's it the willingness to be a fool
in the land of strangers and that's an
act of courage because you also reveal
your vulnerability to the world by
stumbling around but as long as you're
stumbling forward then you're going to
move forward now how do you do that more
concretely are you aim at an ideal right
and you aim at an ideal that's beyond
you now maybe you don't aim to begin
with it an idea that ideal that's so
beyond you that you're crushed by its
magnificence you know maybe that's
that's that's too demotivating to move
you but you could at least conceptualize
yourself as the you that you are with
fewer of the faults that you know of and
that's a good start and I also think
that's associated with the idea of
humility take stock figure out how it is
that you're not who you could be and
then move in that direction and accept
the consequences you know you're you're
going to get slapped a lot but maybe
with each slap you'll straighten up a
little bit especially if you listen even
to the people who are slapping you
because sometimes they're the ones who
can reveal for you very quickly where it
is that you're weak and insufficient so
that you won't have to be that way in
the future so yeah
[Applause]
hello dr. Peterson I have no questions
for you all I ever wanted to do is just
stand in front of you and be able to
thank you for everything you've done
fine my pleasure
oh good morning citizen Peterson you got
a short one yeah I do I mean a question
eight is the best question relax
trust me this one's good but first I'll
break the ice
now I'm going keyboard up said so state
now no icebreaker you want me to get
right into the real question I want you
to get right into the question all right
so this question is about hyper critical
thinking yep now everyone knows the
critical thinking is a great thing to
develop you have to be able to cook I
guess think about your ideas so if
information is presented do you have to
decide if it's legitimate or if there's
some sort of deceit behind it but when
it's taken to its extreme no matter how
great or noble somebody is you can
always find a crack in the armor and try
to figure out how they're covering up
something that's not great about them
you know and you might then discredit
everything they do is just a facade okay
so let me stop you there for a sec
because I want to address two of the
issues that you already brought up so
there's there's the issue of hyper
critical thinking partly in relationship
to yourself and partly in relationship
to others so I'd like to address the
issue with regards to yourself to begin
with so there's this idea that Carl Jung
developed um he extracted it I don't
know from where from some ancient
writings that he was familiar with I
believe they were Jewish writings he
said that classically speaking
traditionally speaking God was viewed to
rule being with two hands the right hand
and left hand and the right hand was
justice and that was you're going to get
what's coming to you but the left hand
was mercy and the idea essentially was
that the cause
could not exist without the proper
combination of justice and mercy
you should get what's coming to you but
people are fallible and they make
mistakes and so it's reasonable to apply
that to yourself you know there's an
idea that's being developed by
psychologists over the last few decades
that people are basically narcissistic
and that they generally feel that
they're better at most things than other
people I don't buy that I don't think
the experimental evidence for that is
very strong and I certainly haven't seen
that for example in my clinical practice
where I've seen that people are
generally far harder on themselves than
they are on other people one example of
that I've written about this in my new
book too is that you know if you have a
pet that's sick and you take it to the
vet and you get medication you're very
likely to give the pet the entire course
of medication to go to the pharmacy to
get the prescription filled to give the
pet the medication to follow it through
but if you are the person who has the
problem yeah you all laughed if you know
the story it's like a 30 you won't even
go fill the prescription and of the
remaining 2/3 of you half of them won't
take it to completion and you think well
why are people like that and I think
it's because they know themselves they
have contempt for themselves because of
their flaws and then they come to
despise themselves and I think that's a
big mistake that's Locke that's too much
justice and not enough mercy and you
know Jung wrote about the biblical
injunction that you should treat your
neighbor as if he were yourself
essentially but he talked about that as
an equation which was quite interesting
so because it's often read as something
like you should be nice to people which
is not what it means at all because
first nice is a very low-end virtue but
it isn't what it means what it means is
that you should you should treat your
neighbor as if he or she is someone that
you wish to encourage and develop but
that you should also have exactly the
same attitude towards yourself which is
weak sort of in some sense regardless of
what your opinion is of yourself
critical let's say hyper critical even
is often the case with people who are
anxious or perhaps who are hyper
conscientious you have to put forward to
yourself the same sympathy we could
say that you would extend to someone
else that you cared for that's the thing
is that you have to come to treat
yourself as if you're someone that you
care for and I mean that technically you
know you detach yourself from yourself
and you think okay well if I was going
to construct a mode of being that was
optimal for this person that I happen to
be what would that look like
and that's sort of independent of
whether or not you think you deserve it
it's like maybe you deserve it maybe you
don't innocent until proven guilty
that's a pretty good policy but you
should come to lay out a mode of being
for yourself that gives you some credit
you know when that will also help you in
your dealings with other people but it's
often very difficult for people to do
that to themselves okay so that's the
that's the first part of that perfect so
it starts out with this hyper critical
thinking and you talked a lot about
Nietzsche's assertion about the death of
God but I see it sort of more like a
willful destruction of the heroic ideal
and I guess several months ago I had
occasion to look up a definition or
explanation for the zeitgeist of modern
victimhood outraged culture and I saw it
in this particular case and I found and
this paragraph okay this has what you
called the rhythmic cadence that just
made my hair stand up on sense and if
you could look at it and read that this
is better than the Lawson
the image of man that dominates in
modern literature in visual art cinema
and theater is primarily a group gloomy
image the Great and the noble are
suspect from the outset they must be
torn from their pedestal so that one can
see through them morality counts as
hypocrisy enjoy a self-deception anyone
who simply puts trust in the beautiful
and the good is either inexcusably in
genuine or acting with evil intent
the truly moral attitude is suspicion
and its greatest success is in exposing
criticism of society is obligatory
it is impossible to find words lurid and
brutal enough to describe the dangers
that threaten us this delight in the
negative is not however unlimited there
exists at the same time an obligation to
be optimistic and the failure to observe
this obligation does not go unpunished
for example anyone who expresses the
view that not everything in the
intellectual development of the modern
period has been correct that is
necessary in some essential areas to
reflect on the shared wisdom of the
great cultures has chosen to make the
wrong kind of criticism he finds himself
suddenly construct confronted with a
resolute apologia
for the fundamental decisions of the
modern age no matter how much delight
one may take indication he is not
permitted to call into question the view
that the fundamental trajectory of
historical development is progress and
that the good lies in the future and
nowhere else you know I thought a lot
about nihilism let's say and and its
justification and I think that a very
powerful justification for nihilism can
be found in the mirror observation that
life is rife with tragedy and
malevolence of which there is no doubt
but then I got suspicious of that
rationale for nihilism over the years
because a counter position to it emerged
and this is something Nietzsche of
course concentrated on as well that had
more to do with resentment it's like you
can imagine negation of the heroic ideal
from despair from the despair of save
produced by tragedy and by exposure to
malevolence but it's also it's
completely and delightfully
irresponsible to negate
heroic ideal because it means that you
don't have any responsibilities and it
seems to me that if you're nihilistic
and prone to criticize the heroic
foundation of let's say Western culture
that one of the first questions that you
could ask yourself is what makes you so
sure that you're appropriately cynical
suspicious and critical and not just
running away as fast as you possibly can
from every bit of responsibility that
you could possibly adopt and I think
that that's a perfectly reasonable
perspective and I think that that is
reflected to some degree in what the
person who wrote this paragraph was
attempting to you guess who it was or
was that fair no I can't really no ha ha
ha ha ha ha
I left you a hint off at them who is it
Cardinal Ratzinger come ah
all right I'm going to take another
question and well done
hello hello how are you doing doing good
dr. Pearson it's been a pleasure 12
weeks 12 12 moments let's say okay so
two weeks ago we talked about your
mischievous suggestion I might say to
cut the university's funding by 25% and
how that might have influenced that sort
of language and Andrew sheers platform
right yeah and so and then you discussed
how you're not exactly sure what your
role is in all of this and and that you
don't want to be in a war and you don't
want to be using warlike language and
and I think I think what you what you
want to be doing is is you're trying to
restore order but not not but not but
not have conflict and and so I so I so
after the after the lecture two weeks
ago I asked you like maybe I maybe I
should do some sales work for your post
modern lexicon website and but I think
I've found a better niche
for someone of my temperament to help
this cause so I think that so I go to
the house University and because so many
students are dropping out especially men
and especially at I think minorities
they've created this team called the
Student Success team or something
Student Success advisors yeah and you've
been extracting credibly successful
crowdfunding for your research and on
your patreon and I think like how much
does it cost for a single person to do
the self altering program well it's two
for one so it's about fifteen dollars
okay so okay so nothing then basically
um but I was thinking that we could
somehow we could incorporate the self
authoring program into this into this
new advisor committee at Dow so that
students can knock yourself out man do
it that's what that's the other like the
data for the future authoring program is
quite clear if students even do it for
an hour before they go to university
they have a thirty thirty percent less
chance of dropping out the first
semester so you know and it would really
night be nice to see some student
organizations that were seriously
devoted to facilitating student success
you might think that's what student
organizations should do in fact well it
seems rather self-evident when you think
about it but you know so I would say
like if you're oriented in that
direction get outer so it's a fine plan
and it's I like the emphasis of it
because you're directing yourself
towards the facilitation of individual
accomplishment and you're at least going
to do very little harm that way and
that's a really good start man you know
that's that because that's that's what
you should think about when you're
setting out to make things better the
first thing you should think is I'm not
so sure I know what I'm doing so why
don't I first attempt to do the least
amount of harm possible and by
concentrating on helping someone develop
their own plan and and implement that
into the future
encouraging them with regards to
whatever success they would like to find
their way there's a pretty low
probability that you're going to act the
terror tyrant and and and play a
detrimental role so good luck
maybe we can communicate thank you yes
I'm gonna send you an email thank you
very much hi dr. Peterson this is the
first of these lectures that I've been
here to listen to but I've listened to
all of them on YouTube so far oh boy
they're not close enough all right wait
that's good okay yeah and I've been
trying to think up this question since
basically the first lecture because I'm
a seminary student at an evangelical
seminary and a lot of what you've been
saying has really been resonating and
it's and it's really been fascinating to
listen to and you know there's many
people who have been asking you
questions like what do you believe about
the resurrection do you believe in God
are you a Christian and all these sorts
of things and you know I've been
listening very closely to all your
answers and have groups of friends on
Facebook or bowling following very
closely say or what Peterson said this
time maybe he's one of us finally or
something like that but but at the same
time other ways that you explain some of
the stories sound very close to what we
call theological liberalism you know in
the 19th century the idea that using
historical critical methods of reading
and interpreting the Bible and
understanding Jesus more as a moral
figure than as a literal historical
figure and whose atonement provides
satisfaction for man so I tried to
figure out what the question was because
I could interpret what some of your
answers were so I'm going to put it in
more of a general way okay where exactly
do you see yourself differing from
traditional Orthodox evangelical
Christianity and and why would you
differ there given how much you you seem
to understand the importance of the
biblical stories and the Western history
in Western history okay okay well that's
a good that's a good question
well I offer obviously I have to answer
in a general way I mean I think that one
of the things that makes me different is
that I take the idea that things are
fourteen billion years old seriously
you know and and the idea of evolution
seriously I mean as Daz does the
Catholic Church by the way and so but I
don't see that as an impediment to the
pursuit that I'm undertaking now I don't
know how to bridge that gap precisely
but I'm not that worried about it I mean
you can't bridge every gap it's just not
possible it would require infinite
knowledge okay and how so that that's
one major because I'm coming at this
from the scientific I really am coming
at this from the scientific perspective
you know like I try to make sure that
everything that I talk about is
commensurate with current scientific
knowledge now current scientific
knowledge no doubt is airing in all
sorts of ways like I think our notion
about exactly how evolution progresses
is flawed in many many ways and the
recent discoveries in the field of
epigenetics which show that you can
actually transmit acquired
characteristics you know has really put
a whole real serious stick in the spokes
of the evolutionary bicycle let's say
but but then I also think the question
is miss asked in some sense because I
gave this lecture series a specific
title for a specific reason and the
lecture series is the psychological
significance of the biblical stories now
I'm not claiming that my psychological
analysis exhausts the significance of
the biblical stories you know they have
multitudes let's say layers of meaning
and some of those layers of metaphysical
and some of them are more specifically
religious and I'm trying the best I can
not to wander into those domains like I
do because it's impossible to keep
yourself bounded you know when you're a
discursive speaker let's say I'm trying
to what I'm trying to do is the sort of
thing that Jung did essentially is to
take a look at these old stories and say
okay well let's look at this from the
perspective of the human psyche and
let's see what the significance can be
and not to say that's all the
significance there is who knows what
significance there is one thing I have
learned about the biblical stories is
that no matter how deep you go into them
you are not at the bottom and so that's
been very very interesting to me and god
only knows about the metaphysical
substructure of reality because human
beings certainly don't
so I don't I don't want to claim that
what I'm doing is a religious
interpretation although you know it
drifts into that direction I want to
stay within the purview of my expertise
such as it is and to say well if you
look at this psychologically here's what
you can extract as as pragmatically
existentially and clinically meaningful
and the rest of it
well the rest of it has to be left in
advance and because I don't have the
capacity to investigate claims that go
beyond that that does not mean that I'm
saying that what I'm doing is reducing
these stories to their psychological
significance even though the psyche is a
grand thing I'm not trying to do that
it's not reductionistic it's a take on
it so people can make up their own minds
metaphysically and they also have to
make up their own minds about how
they're going to act which is really the
crucial issue as far as I'm concerned so
you bet
I I had a question with respect to daddy
presented I believe two weeks ago sorry
a question with respect to data even
presented I believe two lectures ago
regarding the use of psilocybin in
treatment of mental illness yes yes so
subsequently I looked up some of the
recently published a literature and one
yeah studies that I found extremely
striking was one that was published less
than a year ago in The Lancet which is a
very high-end yes
well respected journal yeah and what
they looked at was efficacy in patients
with severe treatment-resistant
depression and what they found is that
in 11 out of 12 of the patients they
showed significant remittance following
it a single dose of the substance up to
three months following the single dose
without additional dosing
so this not only substantiates I suppose
my own experiences but when you read
some of the commentary or review
articles surrounding these types of
topics not with respects to depression
but things like post-traumatic stress
disorder addiction they'll unequivocally
state that these types of results are
completely unprecedented and the realm
of psychiatric medicine yes so I was
wondering - good comment as to whether
or not that type of this rhetoric is
overblown and if not do you see these
being more mainstream in your future or
suspect they'll fall victim to something
along the lines of regulatory capture no
I don't well I don't think they're over
statements and I think I know some of
the people who are engaged in this
research and they're actually very
conservative people like their brave
people but I mean conservative in the
best sense you know they're not they're
not Timothy Leary yeah and I'm not
trying to put down Timothy Leary I'm
really not but you know some caution
would have been a good thing although
you know when something like when the
psychedelics burst onto the scene no one
had any idea what to do with them right
so and we still really don't but the new
research is being conducted very very
carefully but it is really remarkable
that those episodes
are used or those terms are used to
describe the results because those are
the lancet for example is one of the top
end medical journals
you don't see grand claims in The Lancet
right scientists don't write that way
there they're trained from the very
beginning to downplay their results but
they're quite struck by the fact that
these effects occur with single doses
now I think that what we don't know
about psychedelics could fill many many
many thick volumes and they're and
they're absolutely mysterious in their
function purpose effect consequence all
of that and I've always thought that it
was really appalling that we stopped
investigating them back in the 1960s
although it's not been that long you
know 20 years historically speaking it's
really nothing but and no I don't think
that there'll be that the research will
be stopped by regulatory capture because
the people who are doing it now I think
learned their lesson from what happened
in the 60s and are doing it pretty damn
carefully so we can hope that more
results like this are produced and that
they're replicable and that perhaps
they'll prove helpful with any luck yep
hi dr. Pederson I found this lecture
series really really enthralling and it
did why no I spent my time to explain
that I might answer the question
yeah that's okay all I'll get let you
get to the question but I'm curious like
what why do you think that is because
it's a strange thing to have happen like
it's a lecture on the Bible for God's
sake you know it's like it's not
something you'd go to a venture
capitalist with a business plan for so
like what what is it about it you think
that's been that that's had that effect
on you
ha I asked you a question instead look I
don't want to I don't want to put you on
the spot if you want to just move to
your question that's fine but if you
have an answer to that I would be very
interested in doing what it is well it's
it's a thrill to encounter a kind of
means to a metaphysical system that's so
persuasive and potent and I've hadn't
really experienced that a whole lot in
my life huh that's what universities are
supposed to do for people eh that's what
universities are supposed to do for
people they're not supposed to take
people who are barely hanging together
and break them and make them weak
they're supposed to equate them with the
heroic the heroic sub structure of the
human psyche so that they can move out
into the world and thrive and it's an
absolute crime that isn't what's
happening so hooray for that
[Applause]
occurred to me that the kind of
tradition and genre that you are working
in here is that of this sermon now are
you comfortable with that categorization
and why or well see where you go with it
haha well that's the essence of my
question are these sermons and might no
one demo I don't know h er I don't know
you know sorry what was the last part
light one call you a preacher well you'd
certainly call me one and you know I
think that there's a certain overlap and
the overlap but this is being
characteristic of my approach to
education right from the beginning
because I have some rules about what I
lecture what about the topics that I
lecture about and the way that I deal
with it so the first rule is I don't
want to tell you anything that isn't
useful I'm a pragmatist you know like
I'm an American pragmatist that's part
of my philosophical grounding and I
believe that knowledge is tool like and
that the proper thing to do is to to
equip people with the tools to move
effectively in the world and so I want
to make sure that if I offer a story or
a fact for that matter I also say well
here here's why you need to know this
fact it will actually improve your life
or it'll stop you from wandering into a
pit which is approximately the same
thing and then it will also knowing this
will also make you more effective actor
in the social world and that will
improve the social world right and
hopefully that will improve the
environmental world etc etc and so I
would say to the degree that those who
produce sermons are concerned with
producing alterations in behavior which
is our moral alterations say then I
share the same territory with them but I
wouldn't say that that's something that
should be only relegated to the domain
of the sermon because I believe that it
is the job of the universities for
example especially in the damned
humanities to ennoble people and to
enable them to adopt the mantle of
proper citizenship and that we've
forgotten that we've forgotten that or
we're avoiding it or refusing it or
something like that you know and I think
we're using the death of God as an
excuse so I think that to the degree
that I'm a preacher I'm making an error
you know and also to the degree that I'm
politicized I'm making an error I'm
wandering out of my proper territory
when that's the domain that I'm in but
when I'm attempting to assemble multiple
layers of facts towards a practical end
which is what I'm trying to do and the
end is the the annulment of the
individual right that's my goal then
then I'm in my proper domain I'm going
to make mistakes you know I'm going to
wander out of my territory and I try not
to do that but you know it's well it's
part of being a fool you're going to
make mistakes so yeah thanks very much
no problem doc thanks for continuing to
do all the cool stuff that makes
everyone love you that's great
not everyone well uh yeah yeah yeah
that's a generalization there's lots of
people that seem not to love me yeah and
I can't blame him really
anyway yeah I'm going to lead into a
question here so him in your book maps
and rare book maps of meaning uh I got
that quote from Dostoevsky about how
humankind mankind - given all the cakes
in the world yet oh my god so yeah if
you get oh my god is right man that's
one killer quote that's from notes from
the underground eh everyone should read
that because everyone's underground and
it's a great it's a great little journey
through that yeah so it's basically as
you give if you have the perfect utopia
I often use it basically if you have
your most perfect utopia humans will
find a way to screw it up yeah it'll go
out of the way I do at least yeah
because it's what we like we like chaos
and the unknown just talked about this
yeah that's the thing is is that we're
heroic adventurers right we're not we're
not Sybarite
laying on a beach although when you get
the opportunity to do that like make
sure you take it but that's that's not
what that's not that's not the proper
calling of the human soul right we're
out there to conquer chaos and the
unknown and it's in that we find meaning
and that's better than the utopia that's
what Dostoyevsky
god bless his soul Dostoyevsky had that
he was such a genius he had everything
that was wrong with communism figured
out even before it started
amazing really like if you read the
possessed or the devil's which I would
highly recommend although it's a hard
book to get into it takes about a
hundred pages to really get get it get
moving
but Dostoyevsky talks his main character
in that novel is a person who's again a
very powerful person who's completely
possessed by what's essentially the
communist ideology and he's very
effective at moving it forward and
Dostoyevsky lays out brilliantly exactly
the catastrophic consequences of that
both personally and socially and he did
this like thirty years before the
Russian Revolution it's just it's
uncanny I don't know where the hell that
guy was from must have been his epilepsy
you know so yeah I'm glad I got y'all
excited him keep going here basically I
used to use that you know it's kind of
late that a lot of that comes from the
left-wing this utopia we're going
towards with the universal income and
the AI and suddenly the whole
populations can become insanely creative
and with no incentives but it's not that
utopia is not there it's not like this
thing that hasn't happened yet we're in
it we're in it this is the best thing
ever and like all of humanity the
Western civilization like oh my god
putting the material sense I mean oh
it's just toilet paper toilet paper it
just happened anyway that's so serious
like so we have this beautiful thing and
people are trying to take it down at all
cost and and now we go into the dark
phase of my into my question here which
is and it actually goes into
Charlottesville had you know with with
that with with the initial purpose of
protecting the statue was a good thing I
don't I'm not I don't know about
Confederacy except for the big thing but
honestly it's a it's a slippery slippery
slope and the confused souls who in the
bad make this darkened souls for sure
not good they screwed up big-time
the purpose behind it it's so important
because it's going to be fought founding
fathers next anyone who ever contributed
to anything to Western civilization as
we know it is already being it's already
being done James Madison High School in
the States it's getting renamed because
some girls one of the students felt
unsafe and so yeah this is a serious
issue I wanted like I feel like we're
really up against the wall now because
now they found their Nazis man the Nazis
are flooding the streets now so how do
we how do we possibly you know kind of
save our cakes you had to bring it up
didn't you well having the right
degenerated to the identity politics
does not seem to be a positive solution
so one of the things I would say is that
like I understand why the identity
politics that has been practiced so
assiduously and so devastatingly by the
left has been co-opted by the right I
understand that but then here's what I
would say to the people on the right who
are playing that game if you play the
game of your enemies and you win you win
their game you don't win
that's not victory you just become the
most successful exponent of their
pathology how is that a good thing it's
a bad thing so what does that leave
people as although as an alternative
well I don't think that the Caucasians
let's say should revert to being white I
think that's a bad idea
it's a dangerous idea and it's coming
fast and I don't like to see that I
think the whole group identity thing is
seriously pathological I think we've
made big mistakes in Canada I understand
why at least to some degree in that
respect and that large mistakes are
being made all over the Western world
where we're making you
group identity the most important thing
about you
I think that's reprehensible I think
it's devastating
I think it's genocide 'el in its
ultimate expression I think it will
bring down our civilization if we pursue
it we shouldn't be playing that game so
what's the alternative you know I've
thought for a long time about a
political career really forever since I
was like 12 really for a long time and
I've always decided against it because
it seemed to me that the proper level of
analysis with regards to the solution of
the problem that we're facing isn't
political and that's why I think it's a
mistake when what I'm doing gets
politicized either by me or others I
think that the way that you deal with
this is to put yourself together I
really believe that is that because I
think that individual people are far
more powerful they're certainly far more
evil than they're willing to consider
but that's also a sign of their
unbelievable power so I think that what
you do is you aim high and put yourself
together and stay the hell away from the
ideologues because they're hiding
they're hiding behind a wall they're not
able to come out and fight on their own
behalf and so the way forward through
the ideological mess and that's the
lesson of Western culture is to place
the individual at the place of paramount
importance and to make the group
identity emerge only when necessary and
secondarily
if ever and so you can do that you can
do that now you can do that tomorrow
like you can put your life together and
again as I mentioned to the other young
men who asked the question is you won't
hurt anyone doing that right you pick up
your goddamn responsibilities sort
yourself oke fix up your family right
and then you can be a force for good in
the culture and if enough people do that
the ideological mess will just evaporate
it'll just disappear I think that's the
way you show people the right path
forward to is that you say well look um
we would like we would like it so much
if you could thrive as an individual
drop your cult-like affiliation right
step out of the shadows the demonic
shadows you
ideological possession and step forward
as a fully developed person into the
light do it by example
that's your that's your best bet man so
that's what it looks like to me
I'm going to take one more question and
then I'm going to there is a young man
from Kentucky here Brian
it's Brian here ok so I'm going to
answer one more question and I'm going
to let you take Mike okay all right good
evening dr. Peterson good evening
everybody
I also want to thank you first for your
lectures that I've been following on
YouTube mainly and to say that they have
been well life changing wouldn't be an
overstatement great and I'm one of the
crazy people increasing your views on
YouTube because I flew in from Belgium
last night to be here and and it's like
3 a.m. for me right now
and English is not my first language so
bear with me
I I would have many burning questions to
ask you but I thought it was fair and
necessary to pick one and it would be
this one there are concepts that recur
in your lectures with this one you only
mentioned once in your early videos on
Bill c16
about self-esteem you said you don't
believe in the existence of self-esteem
the way to teach children they're all
special you think you boost their
confidence but the only result is that
some get a narcissistic the reason why
I'm interested in that is about standing
up for yourself
and it is and when I try to you know do
it yeah I see that rational argument
facing rationality doesn't get the best
result in negotiations that's why you
learn how to be socialized by playing
rough and tumble it's not an
intellectual conversation that gets you
socialized so I'm also reading that book
suggested about by Stephen Hicks
explaining of modernism yes I wasn't
really familiar and I've been listening
to a lot of talk to him later this week
so that might be fun and I'm trying to
read with fresh eyes because
having it doctrine aided by you of
course very critical and there's one
more point that I have to agree with the
postmodernist and that is the world
seems to me as I observe it a place
where powers are at play it's not
rationality delete that so when I'm in a
weak position and I want to fight back
not to get resentful I find that it's
not a rational argument that will get me
there there's something else that I
don't do and that I should be doing and
I don't know what it is so you see the
relation with self-esteem seems to me
that people who think of themselves
start in a better position in this game
ok so ok ok great yeah alright so
there's a lot in that question so the
first thing is is there's a problem with
the measurement of self-esteem and that
actually matters because self-esteem is
a psychological concept a scientific
concept if you like and you have to get
the measurement right and you can
predict self-esteem almost perfectly by
measuring someone's extraversion
and subtracting from that their negative
emotionality or neuroticism so it's
actually just a combination of big five
traits and so people who are extroverted
who feel a lot of positive emotion and
who are and who don't feel a lot of
negative emotion score high on scales of
self-esteem
ok so conceptually it's a non-starter
because you're not going to move
people's levels of neuroticism let's say
by trying to get them to feel good about
themselves
ok now having said that that doesn't
mean that you shouldn't encourage people
right now there's this psychologist
named Jerome Kagan who's quite a great
psychologist developmental psychologist
I think he's emeritus at Harvard at the
at the at the moment he studied temper
mentally inhibited children you can so
they're basically kids who are high in
neuroticism probably low and
extraversion and he found that if those
chilled and you can identify them as
early as six months right it's very very
inculcated in their temperament he found
that if you encouraged them in the world
you could shift
them into a more stable personality
configuration and what you basically did
was when they were manifesting signs of
distress instead of encouraging them to
withdraw and retreat which is what they
might be attempting to do you encourage
them to go out and explore so for
example if you have a temper mentally
inhibited child and you go to a
playground and there's kids out there
like you have an extroverted emotionally
stable kid three years old as you put
them on the ground their feet are
already moving right like a puppy over
water and you let them go and they just
run to the to the kids and they're there
and then you have to drag them away but
if you have a temper mentally inhibited
child the child will sort of stand
around your legs and sort of peek out
you know and then what you do is wait it
out let them watch encourage them to
move a little bit forward encourage them
to take their steps out into the unknown
and the strange land and don't let them
withdraw like you can do it you have
they're slower to warm up they'll warm
up they'll habituate and if you
continually expose your inhibited child
to the things that make them anxious in
measured doses then you can transform
their psychophysiological temperament
now you're probably not going to shift
them way the hell out onto the
extroverted emotionally stable end but
you can make a big difference that's
very different than making them feel
good about themselves which is such a
you need to curse you need to curse when
you discuss that concept right so it
isn't the improved their self-esteem it
isn't how you feel about yourself right
it's how you act effectively in the
world and how you're trained to do that
so okay now then you were talking about
negotiation right and you said well
don't you said something like don't
people who feel good about themselves
aren't they able to negotiate better and
it's I know that's a poor paraphrase
excuse me but negotiation is actually a
practical issue to some degree like the
first thing is that you have to figure
out what you want because you were
saying well it's not merely rational
it's like yeah yeah that's for sure you
have to bargain from a position of
authority let's say not power Authority
is a better word but you don't have
authority unless you know what you're
talking about and unless you can bring
some unless you can bring some
let's say force it's not that's not the
right word you can negotiate without
anyone unless you can say no and you
can't say no unless you've set yourself
up with alternatives so when you go to
your boss and you negotiate for a raise
you need to have the sort of CV that
enables you to go find another job and
you have to have your CV prepared and
you have to have looked for another job
and you have to be able to get one
because then you can go in there and say
I'm not as productive as I could be at
my current level of remuneration it's
not reflective of what I'm able to do
and I want this and this is what will
happen if you give me this this would be
the good things that will happen and
what do you think of that and the person
is going to know even by the way that
you hold yourself while you're having
the discussion whether or not you're
someone with options and you can't fake
that well you can but it's not helpful
like it just doesn't work for very many
iterations you have to it's it's not
rationally you're preparing yourself for
battle that's what you're doing and you
can't be weak when you prepare prepare
yourself for battle because if the
person says no I'm not giving you a
raise which is exactly what they should
say because what are they going to do
just like sprinkle the money around you
need to be able to say okay then there
will be consequences that you don't like
and that's what it means to say no to
someone no means if you continue to push
this things will happen that you don't
like now in that case it'll be all be
part and take my talents with me and if
they don't care well then you're in the
wrong business or you don't have any
talents to begin with right which is so
it in order to negotiate properly and
then this is more difficult for people
who are agreeable for example because
there tend to be more conflict averse
you have to put yourself in a position
where you can you can push back as hard
as you're going to be pushed on and that
means you have to open your you have to
open up your space of available options
because otherwise the person says no one
that's it you're done well you'll lose
that it's it's as straightforward as
that now with regards to the self-esteem
part is practice on small things because
you build the skills forget about the
self-esteem it isn't about being
confident or feeling
confidence or any of that it's about
knowing bloody well how to negotiate
start with small things you know so
you'll notice that there are things in
your relationships in particular that
aren't the way you want them to be and
that you could see how could be improved
it's like figure out how they can be
improved negotiate with your partner
make the incremental improvement keep
doing that you'll get better and better
at it and then you'll be able to go out
and have a harder negotiation in the
world so to set a skills there's an
attitude behind it you know and it's
easier for some people than others but
fundamentally it's a set of skills no
problem alright so now we have something
interesting and I expected to close this
off with the floor is yours dr. Peterson
I'd like to say thank you for making
your videos available online they've had
a great effect on me over the last year
I actually found them a few years ago
but sometime around July or August of
last year I got hooked I would wake up
at like 5:00 a.m. in the morning to
watch your maps of meaning releases the
new ones the old ones excetera
I found myself inspired by both the
academic and technical material as well
as what I might term the more fatherly
directives or wisdom I shared this with
my family and my friends as well as my
girlfriend she's here tonight as well
she's been following the biblical series
but what I'd like to say is thank you
for inspiring me to stand up and face
something that I've been afraid of all
my adult life and thank you for granting
me the permission to ask this question
here it's actually for my girlfriend
will you please stand up
you
so some might say given that we are a
couple of primates full of snakes it's
pretty miraculous that we haven't killed
each other but I think you're pretty
great and we've been talking about
commitment and I think I'm ready I know
I'm ready to commit to a life with you
of sorting ourselves out
I'd like to clean some rooms with you
and even as scary as the shackles of
marriage have been made to sing to us
I'm thinking about forever and simply
Mao in my words I love you dearly you
feel like home I never want to lose that
will you marry me if you want to come
here
so you're saying you're gonna shackle
yourself to me and never run away then I
shall suffer the rest of my life with
you